this ear biscuit is brought to you by
Squarespace the all I want platform that
makes it fast and easy to create your
own professional website or online
portfolio for a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase go to Squarespace
calm and use the offer code our and L
that's our a in the l-listen here's the
deal you need a website and you need to
just make it yourself because it's just
simpler that way now that there is
Squarespace but B you need a website
that looks good you don't want you don't
want a crappy website no but some people
do that's the thing there is a movement
out there of people trying to make
purposely crappy cheesy websites but
we're not there the square face cannot
do that right they're not gonna help
with that this this is for the people
who want a a nice-looking website
somebody that you want something unique
you don't want something that looks like
some template somewhere that's the thing
they've got all these designs that you
can start with in styles but all these
options to make it totally customized
totally unique and you cannot make it
look bad you can try we challenge you
try it
it won't happen it's still gonna look
good at your website hey Ralph your
website looks good if your name is Ralph
this was worth it that was for you Ralph
and hopefully Ralph comms not-taken or
that you have it it probably is
Squarespace can help you with that start
a trial without a credit card required
start building your website today and
then when you do decide to sign up for
Squarespace make sure you use our offer
code RA and DL are ndele to get your 10%
off your first purchase and show your
support for ear biscuits right it's a
great way to show support for the show
again thanks to Squarespace for the
support of ear biscuits okay let's make
one another ear biscuit
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett we do this every week and up close
a personal conversation with somebody
interesting from the internet all right
this week you've been asking for him so
we finally got him to come in here toby
turner tobuscus one of the most prolific
and successful youtube creators out
there and i gotta say we got inside of
his head
a little bit that well that sounds like
that sounds like we were messing with
him right know we gained an
understanding yeah well I'm just trying
to make it seem like even a little bit
more tantalizing than it actually was a
great conversation we learned about his
creative process we hear the story about
how I found this enormous YouTube
success and how he's found his distinct
comedic voice well we also discussed how
he's managing his personal life kind of
getting that side of things we might
have even discussed some high profile
past YouTube relationships but before we
get into that I do want to talk about an
interesting experience we had here in
the studio recently you may have seen
our our video that we released on our
main channel that featured some naked
Russian men this is the first time that
we have I don't I wouldn't say it's the
first time that we've included nakedness
and in our in our videos you were naked
and wrote some bacon on it I well I well
again it was apparent nakedness there
was some bacon over some important parts
yes and utaite you for the record you
were not naked underneath the bacon
correct and I got to say it we made it
look very much like these Russian men
were naked
and they indeed were also not naked but
I've got to say that this is not a
normal part of a rhett and Link video
shoot to have basically naked people on
set and yeah and yeah we I would like
for us to process this we haven't really
talked about it but yeah I think that I
didn't know if I wanted to talk about
this it's one of those things well maybe
if I don't talk about it it never
happened
well once it's a YouTube video it's you
know no I mean just the vibe on set
because I know what you're going to talk
about but you can tell you won't tell me
what a building it up too much
interesting how it came together because
we originally came up with the idea that
we would have a couple of Russian men in
a banya we would have turned the
bathroom into a banya a traditional
Russian bath and so we steamed it up
actually looked like steam but it was
actually a fog machine that we put in
the bathroom and we had these two men
who
through just the the casting process one
of the cool things about being out here
in LA is that there are all these people
out here who are just actors just
waiting to be in a role and you go
through sites like la casting or
sometimes you might use Craigslist and
so you find all these people who submit
for a role so when use a casting website
we're you know it's TV helped us with
this you start you put a call out there
for an older man who looks Russian and
then all of a sudden you have like 50
people submit for this role and then
you're going through these things saying
okay who looks the most Russian and I
mean who we can't see anything but like
their headshot yeah we didn't ask him to
send nude pics to us right but in the
description we do say will appear to be
naked you know not actually appear naked
but appear to be naked in this video so
people like putting these little notes
like I've done something like this
before I don't know what that means
not at we don't want to know but all I
know is that these two guys showed up I
think Richard and Alan I can't remember
it one of them was named Alan they show
up Boris and yeah Boris and Yakov is
what we named them on set these guys
show up and you know where should they
were already naked with their part of
the video and then they're in the lobby
waiting to kind of come in and Stevie
comes in like these they're ready and so
I go out there to the lobby and I see
one of them has a robe on and the other
guy is just in a shirt in his underwear
like he did not come prepared he did not
have a robe side there's this older man
and I'm not just talking underwear he
had on bikini briefs essentially is what
he had to have on well we gave him those
oh we okay we did okay those were those
were slightly in the buff and buck naked
before that and I gotta admit that it
was a little awkward for me because I
shook both of their hand well you're not
supposed to make eye contact with the
crotch I did in their hand I saw you you
weren't even in there okay but I did
think about that I was like don't look
at his underwear look at his face when
you shake this well I I gotta be honest
I didn't have any trouble with that well
I mean it wasn't like I've desired it
but there's just something about this
letter into the Sun right it's you
right so but the funny thing was is we
shot the little scene with them in the
in the bath room and then we had to
break for lunch and I simulated
nakedness
at that point too by the way you did and
I was literally standing two feet from
these guys it looks like I'm further in
the shot but in the room I had on why I
had on pants I had on yoga pants yeah
you did what you had on the pants that I
stands are pants the ice dancer pants
and they were very tight and I didn't
have anything else on I was shirtless
but the thing that the moment that it
was awkward awkward this whole thing was
was during the lunch break when I come
downstairs and they've got the food out
and everybody's eating and I see the one
guy in the robe that's okay that makes
sense this guy's got the briefs on
underneath there but then I see what the
other dude Boris and he has on just a
shirt and he's just in his briefs he
going through the buffet line all he did
was put a t-shirt back on
right it's like dude don't you know that
that t-shirt doesn't even cover your
whole belly right it doesn't crush your
briefs dude but I mean and didn't you
didn't you drive here with pants on I
mean he could have easily put on pants
to even lunch I just don't wonder why he
didn't I think that he was just lounging
around it comes down to just a comfort
level he made he made a decision that he
was going to be comfortable in his own
skin literally and not much more and I
gotta admit I think it comes down to age
you really think so yeah once you're an
old guy I mean just think about those
old professors at NC State you'd go work
out in the gym you go to but people just
walking around naked everywhere because
they're just cuz they're old
you said why put clothes on your old I'm
you've seen it all but I gotta say that
personally I really enjoy being naked
there are even times where you know I
have a fenced-in back enough fenced-in
backyard but like there's a wall there's
a wall around my backyard and I can see
out of it and people who are passing by
on the street can see my head because
I'm so tall right yeah but they can't
see the lower half of my body so there
are many times that I go out in the
backyard
and I think of myself it's a beautiful
California day it's 73 degrees again
today I just want to be out here in the
back
naked no one would know maybe a la cop
would fly over in a helicopter and see
me but who cares about that there's no
law against that you can be in your
backyard and I can never bring myself to
do it I think about how glorious it
would be to be in my natural state just
walking around in the backyard you
actually think this yeah and I never can
bring myself to do it because I like the
idea of it but but then I'm just
uncomfortable with the reality of it
well you're the I mean so you're saying
that walled backyards are the gateway
drug to nudist colonies I mean that's
what's happening here no no you you're
one you're one high wall away from a
nudist colonists that's precisely why I
don't do it because I would not enjoy
would enjoy alone you say that rabble
joy alone not enjoy being a part of a
college Bob I'm not gonna come in that
mood that back gate again I'm gonna I'm
gonna just be calling you over the
always text me first yeah I'm gonna
start texting you are you gonna keep
your phone well I mean if you're nude
I'll hold it you're gonna you're gonna
get nude back there and then it may be
it may be a few months it may be a few
years but you're gonna you're gonna be
telling me and these kind listeners hmm
that you've you've slipped on the
slippery slope of nudity well and you
are now you're a colonist of the of the
nude zone I'm not worried about the nude
colony I'm worried about Google Maps
okay I'm worried about being naked on
Google Maps
Malakai and then the helicopter the
technology is only gonna get more
advanced and the cameras are gonna get
sad right you're right you're not too
much street video much satellite yeah
Street View doesn't make it into my
backyard but satellite view does and be
the hold on of course looking at me from
straight straight on from right above me
I don't know how much you'd see I don't
want to go any more detail on that
anyway it's funny how I've just I
haven't done this before on an ear
biscuit but for some reason I was
picturing Tobey listening to dizzy or
biscuit and he's like man this is what
you guys talk about before you had this
conversation we had such a good
conversation and then you you tee it up
with this near nakedness what nude
conversation to set up a really forced
analogy and that is I really feel like
we strip
toby turner on this week's episode of
ear biscuits well mark my words I mean
you're gonna be there and I'm not I I
follow you and stepping into a lot of
stuff yeah uh and that's okay but this
is not gonna be one of those things okay
and I told you I want to do it alone
just me and Google Maps just me and the
rest of the world okay let's let's let's
get on let's go down to the Toby thing
yeah this is about Toby Turner this is
not about being naked Toby if you
haven't heard of him before he's
currently the only youtuber that claims
to spots on youtubes top 50 most
subscribed channels list his most
well-known series is his literal
trailers on his Tobuscus channel and
also his popular parody songs plus his
gaming channel is amongst the top 5 in
his category on YouTube with over 6
million subscribers so we can also be
seen in the leading role and Cartoon
Network's the high fructose adventures
of Annoying Orange let's get into it
[Music]
okay last time that you came to this
building a very interesting thing
happened it was like a mix-up on the
location what's your version why I don't
know if there was a mix up as much as we
just went to not your building but also
I was hat like they were waiting for
someone already right is that what it
was yeah they were waiting for somebody
and they're right this way my oh great
so they took me to the back of the
building and they were doing a shoot and
then the directors like who's that
question we had a video shoot this is
how crazy it is okay so we were shooting
a video then you made a cameo in and our
address is a certain number in a certain
Road but it has West it is the West
version of that road yeah I do the same
exact dress without the West in it was
also shooting a video on the same day at
the same time and when you came in there
they escorted you you just thought I
mean it this all worked out I am at the
rhett and Link shoot I'm here I'm not
sure
complicated I think it might have
actually been like kind of next door to
you yeah I think so yeah cuz I write
because we walked as a hairstylist next
door well we were walking distance I
thought I don't know I remember walking
and I don't do that a lot so it stands
ok alright well because there is a there
is a studio that has the exact same
address within it how far away is it
it's maybe walking this I think it's a
couple of miles so really sprinting this
not Toby well how do you know my walking
well you just said gentle walk much yeah
because I get there instantly oh thank
you you don't walk much because you
sprint off is what you're saying yeah
yeah it makes a better story if it was
that other play Healey is what I do you
should know that by now I do now but by
the time that this air biscuit comes out
the depressing song will be up but it
does this biscuit of the year come out
and like in like a couple of weeks okay
yep so we we're a little bit ahead we
wanted to post it on today but we ended
up I guess high tunes was a little slow
to process the I've never done the the
podcast thing so that was our first
podcast and we submitted our we wanted
to push the podcast from the depressing
song got it okay because if I say the
song is on iTunes now the song is going
like an hour ago
but since then we instead caught up like
a movie night thing that's not well
researched this podcast is nicely done
so it's kind of tricky sometimes we
don't our to get to so we don't know yet
if we made the cut we know we said you
can see it we sent some video to you to
make cameo I know but we don't know what
we're in the cup yeah I didn't even know
if you knew it's one of those things
that okay does make the cut means made
made me cut you out it's awesome you
guys are amazing and you should watch it
we could I could show you at some point
no a pre preview okay so we're in a -
yeah you were and a lot of the time they
listen to this it's out yeah and people
have experienced yep hmm that's explain
all the motions I like being in the
future the present in the future the
same phrase that is something as well
just intrigues me and the past sort of
like a second later you go to all three
states at some point right now we're in
the past where we
you're not now let me out when you
started yeah yeah this could make you go
crazy so I write a song be it the
depressing song or any other song what's
what's the process what's the Meccan
well depressing song is a parody what
did you know that yeah well I listened
to the sample on iTunes okay
yeah did you hear that you heard they
say something say something yeah it's a
line you don't be able to do it with
with my grenade bro yeah
April laughs yeah yeah she's fantastic
so we I don't know how it came around
because I was writing or unique like
some other thing that was original and
then I just you know I was like hone
write a really sad song and then I
started thinking about say something
which is freaking crazy sad yes and I
wrote okay so we were we were in
Amsterdam a year ago me and Seth
Hendricks who do you know him
mm-hm he had we had the same jacket we
owned the same jacket oh yeah that that
guy yeah got along with a jacket okay
yes
wait wait so we went to Amsterdam a year
ago and it was it was awesome
and in it rained so the first couple
days it didn't rain and everyone was
amazed that it hadn't rained why were
you in a few days first of all well we
went to we had those of meetup in London
and I was like while we're in Europe
let's just go to like you know a couple
different another form of Europe yes all
over it as many places as we could I
don't know why he picked that hurry I do
but I don't because come on let's
Amsterdam it's awesome I almost got
killed like twice but it's a nicest
place in the world I'm just loud what do
you mean people people blogging in
places where he shouldn't be from
hogging like we're like this oh yeah ugh
in front of prostitutes I know and
that's they I was asked them while they
had a submachine gun out aimed at me it
was kind of awesome is this a pimp
situation coming money a glob I was a
very like a BD you wearing pimp that was
a pimp that is in the woods sometimes
friendly hopefully it was wood color was
not City colored BD
anyway that's a little confused okay
so you were in a blogging it says no
cameras I'm like this is a phone
oh and that didn't work bill joke didn't
phone camera thing yeah yeah I was like
maybe I don't know that yet but you
survived yeah I'm here I'd lived I
didn't you know but you decided to write
a depressing song yeah okay okay here's
a so this guy was playing mad world and
he had this huge PA system and I was
playing to everyone in this large area
next to our hotel and so I I kind of
like right then wrote this version of
mad world which is you know it's it's an
older song it's great but it's like I
wrote this song to make people feel bad
ruin your day ruin your day anyway so
that was the idea and so this one is you
know I wrote the song to make you
depressed which is just I think that's
my question so what you're telling me is
that you were just about town with your
friend with the same jacket in Amsterdam
and you heard the song over a PA and you
started singing I started seeing what
kind of yeah so I started seeing
everybody and I was probably magining it
but I was rainy and ever just looked so
sad that was it's cuz he's there playing
freakin mad world and broadcasting so
you were you were vlogging not at this
time no so this was I feel like I'm in
court you were second more like a Senate
hearing because there's a two of us oh
okay no there's a panel no I don't know
anything about that that's like you know
it requires we reading about stuff that
happens political things I guess what
I'm what I'm interested in is the fact
that you wrote this song
extemporaneously in the same way that
like when you're playing a video game
and you start singing that's kind of how
my sword kind of thing but you were
doing that you weren't doing it for your
audience quote you were doing it for
like your friends right there yeah yeah
yeah you know it is weird okay I don't
know if you ever get to this point but
it's weird making something that making
a joke that you think is really funny
when you're not recording yes exactly
yeah exactly but you know I just want
freaking people to laugh
but it does I'm like I know I have to
redo this later and it's not gonna be as
genuine cuz I made it before it's weird
so you wrote again in my head the the
seas of the depressing song were written
just sorta top of your head there but
then you repurpose that concept yeah
yeah that's kind of like a literal to be
sad about everything so well I think
that's one of the the the hallmarks of
your brand right and you personally
here's well is ideas right so that's
thank you you go back you know going
back to when you first got on YouTube
all the way back you know six you know
pretty much right around the same time I
think within somebody pointed out I saw
on researched Rory I saw on Twitter owe
you a lot of research May 14th 2006
a'mma 10 days we join between us joining
what that's awesome yeah so we've been
wow you've been there for a long time
did we beat him by 10 days we were think
we were Judas I know we copied we were
10 days
dude I didn't make you I knew about you
guys way before I knew about myself but
you know I want to come back to those
early days and how you got to that point
but the thing I find really interesting
is that you're an ideas guy you have all
these ideas for all these series and all
in the in the music videos and
everything and which is it's similar we
haven't has seen nearly the success you
have but is similar you know our brains
work in a similar way and when you do
something where like oh I totally see
how why you thought that works so great
cuz it's weird okay meeting with you
guys are ridiculously talented and like
meeting with you know other youtubers
that you respect a lot you you it is
kind of weird especially to send you the
sign like don't hate it
like when I say you the depresses I was
like you know you know watch it and I
keep seeing a person moving and it's
your spinny wheel and it's not even
moving aside I tricks yeah it's an
optical illusion we have the missing
wheel of mythicality is moving in your
mother
but but yeah I mean I you guys amazing
you have to say that it will take it
okay I think your point is well my point
is is that a guy who is so known for his
ideas and has seen so much success with
your ideas to think that it today hmm
your gaming channel is your number one
channel yeah we're talking what are
these six million subscribers yeah I
mean I think I think view I have and a
half million subscribers on your
Tobuscus channel yeah yeah yeah it may
not be the place that you it's not your
ultimate creative outlet I know that
your Tobuscus channels your creative
outlet yeah but like how does that how
does that work Howard you did you see
it's hard to jet law I mean I did well
when it started getting way more
subscribing there's also a big part of
YouTube is just having a good schedule
and I don't with Tobuscus I mean I do
now it's it's much better than was we're
posting I guess every Tuesday and
Thursday and Friday we're gonna have
whatever right it's not that good but
it's better than one yeah I want to say
it yeah because what you got a movie
exactly no we do movie nights every
Friday but I mean everyone does in
efflux movie nights for a while and I
wanted I wanted to try a Mystery Science
Theater thing where I would just make
jokes over bad movies that people just
said we're bad I mean if this is your
movie dude it's great I'm sure it's a
great movie people laugh because of it
but anyways so yeah tobyGames is a place
for me to get idea to to be I think like
while I'm playing it doesn't look like
it but I do and and then I got write
down you know ideas for songs and stuff
that I make up in in Minecraft I think
minecraft is the most it makes you feel
creative because that's the whole point
yeah and I don't play it enough at new
mean we think of it your channel kids
our kids are into it I mean it's it's
not it's not about I mean I'm starting
to you know saying that I know and to
demean I'm just saying that world it's
different well I mean do come on you
know when you play the game and talk you
have to rely cure' brain goes into
overdrive there's like people gonna be
bored of this really fast and so like
you were you know that those my first
thing starting out is I didn't want
people to get bored cuz I do and so I
wanted to entertain people like me that
would have this like the same feel and
your thought was I'm gonna do the
Mystery Science Theater thing we
videogame oh yeah because you were
playing video games and yeah they were
other people creating like let's play
channel beginning I'm no I mean that
there were that's place yeah but there
weren't uh there were no comedy ones
that I saw I mean I'm sure there were I
just because you're in July 2010 okay
it's when you started that channel sure
what when I started like looking into it
everybody that I saw was very serious
about about gaming and I mean like my
whole life I'm just like not like I like
not being good cuz it's fun to you know
like I don't want to play somebody's
gonna kill me over and over and over I
want to play somebody that we're both
kind of mad you know clunky and like
they're people are very serious and you
saw it as a comedic outlet yeah not be
good at games and post videos about it
and it was a way that you know I could
just tell some jokes without having to
like leave my house well the amazing
thing is is how well it has worked and a
lot of people try it who are not funny
you're funny naturally so it's it's it
works but it's almost like I do you feel
that you were partially responsible for
this movement dude I can't
I haven't I mean I feel like if someone
didn't see someone else do it and they
saw me and you know it makes them laugh
I think yeah it makes you want to do it
also but I'm you know I just don't watch
a lot of YouTube videos for a youtuber
just because I'm so like I'm always like
I need to get this next idea I have this
probably don't think driving me drives
me crazy but it's it's fun and that's
how I make my favorite stuff so I mean
hopefully yeah hopefully I got some
people into it because I think it's an
amazing thing to do it's really good for
you dude but did you see it coming
whenever you started to create these you
like yeah okay I could I know how I can
be funny I see the challenge and talking
keeping the chatter up and finding humor
in anyways knowing when you're talking
too much and and I sometimes I know like
I'm like I shut up you know and so I try
to balance it it's it's good I think
it's a it's a good exercise and it's
like a nice it's like a prophet did you
see it did you have the foresight when
you start it and started clicking in
your mind that this was gonna take over
YouTube
nezam as if the video game let's play
phenomenon no no I guess not I mean I
once I once tobyGames
you know started
get like everyday I would post a video
and I would expect it to get thousands
of views I'm like this is gonna end up
being better than Tobuscus like in terms
of more people will it'll reach more
people but it's uh it's not it's good
for me to play games it makes me feel
like I'm not wasting time because you
know I want to share like because I mean
I used to play games and my brother and
we would just freaking make jokes and
make each other laugh the whole time and
that's kind of that's what I wanted to
go for for this I didn't I didn't really
see it taking over and I think it's I
think it's great because it's a it's a
it's nice it's like a way to it's a
certain thing but it's it's not like I
still think music for me is how I really
like speak the most freely I'm more
proud of my music stuff if you had to
give up one or the other if you had to
you would give up I mean I would elgu
doe do music definitely I love music
it's my favorite but gaming is freaking
awesome now is there a is there less
money and game I I don't know if they're
all of a sudden was some sort of revenue
split now that you don't make as much
money off a gaming because it's the
because of the video game owners I'll
get a cut of the money
I you know I'm not I don't pay attention
I haven't looked at any of my anything
for like a year I don't I can because as
soon as you look at your like but it's
not about that you know got it but I I
should I just know I'm not smart but I
honestly don't know I I don't know I had
a you know whatever it said we've these
networks and things I've jumped from
network to network a couple times just
because I want to see like what's the
what's the hype and and meet everybody
and work with everybody I'm not really
sure I don't I don't know as much about
it as like you know so Olga would always
you know she's so interested in in a
couple things
okay she's awesome and she would kind of
give me advice on that and and mm-hmm
the business aspect yeah but in terms of
I mean I do a lot of sponsor I do as
many sponsorships as like as I can
because I feel like they're like a class
project you know and and that's kind of
why I really got into doing sketches
because I want to make funny commercials
cuz commercials are so they can be so
funny or they suck yeah like I'd rather
be making stuff that I think is awesome
you know so you saw the business model
and that
with the video gaming it and the ins and
outs of things that are kind of out of
your control what what cut you get of it
that's not really your thing to get into
it I mean if it goes away then it goes
away I just want to do it just because I
want to you know entertain myself and
whoever wants to listen and it's also
cool for me it helps me make make songs
and and it's it's fun like minecraft is
freaking fun to sing song we have
another song also by we I mean myself I
just such a big ego but it's it's mine
the diamond I understand that too you
die terabrite made the freaking guitar
yours about time that I find da moon
dudes about Tom Ned mom dad I'm around
it's way too intense is that out yeah no
okay
no three weeks your songs all have this
consistent energy to them that is how
would you describe it what genre is the
Tobuscus songs listen it's like a it's
like a rock when it shouldn't be and
your melodies - I like the way they
don't know don't know it's in his hands
exactly yeah it's I think that's just my
natural beat that I decide well there's
also a chord that I always use on piano
and I don't know what it's called but
like for some reason that's what I
always draw - you like the dramatic
silent no no no no no no no no like
that's the same chord as most of them
but did you I mean I know you can't
anticipate some of this stuff but you
know I you know when I go back home my
cutting my nephews fact in North
Carolina yeah I go to North Carolina my
nephew's are huge fans of yours and and
it's just like I feel like there's
something in the the melody the melodic
choices maybe what your natural rhythm
and your natural melody that somehow
speaks to the heart of a 13 year old
it's some magnificent way it's can you
describe it can you quantify it yeah
dude I'm trying its scientific
yeah yeah there's somebody out there who
could explain
how your choices I did a lot to the mind
of a 13 year old boy I actually like
started learning piano when I was like I
mean I took piano lessons like my whole
childhood until I was like you know 14
or somebody around there and I think
that that and and and listen like I I
only wanted to learn the really
difficult freaking stuff that would take
me all summer and I would just not go
outside for a while so I learned a
couple really hard songs like what like
well I mean like moonlights not a third
um which is the I could learn I learned
like the first seven minutes of the song
or something it's way too it's a long
song but now I can't it's not I haven't
practiced so what was anything that I
feel like that helped me get in the
musical thing like when you do when
you're young it's so important to
freaking play piano and when you so now
when you play you think you're
channeling your inner 13 year old lean
for a while yeah and then you came back
to the piano yeah I picked up where
you're 13 years off and I'm stuck there
limbo so why did you choose why was that
your approach to piano at what age will
be talking you were playing the
moonlight sonata mm was it an
entertainment thing like if I can learn
to play this this will be this will just
rock the crowd yeah I mean I think my
family like I wanted I wanted to like
like my mom like listen to my pianist of
all time and she you know like I would
impress her so much by like learning
Pocahontas which is you know wonderful
but I'm like we'll check this out and
then I would just like practice for so
long and then you know impress her and
she'd go crazy she's adorable she all we
recorded the recorded a video of her
watching depressing song actually it's
hilarious really it's so funny what was
it like growing up with you you were you
grew up in Florida most that's mostly
right yeah yeah nice Ville I was born in
Mississippi in bloom so a Snoop Dogg
where miss knew in Macomb Macomb and
then when did you move to nice velour
six weeks of Macomb I was like I'm done
and you don't remember much about Macomb
and I blocked it out no but yeah we we
were Air Force I mean I wasn't in the
Air Force at the time forever but so we
we got stay boarded by so your dad or
your mom dad okay in the air for what
did he do in the Air Force uh you know I
don't know it's classified I don't know
I've never asked I assume it's awesome
yeah but yeah so then is dad still
around yeah yeah he's why he's in Vegas
now okay he's not in the air for Nadia
Morse in the air okay force him there at
all so did you grow up with both parents
and yeah yeah yeah them and my brother
my sister and then my niece happened and
then she started giving all the presents
for Christmas and your niece live with
you yeah yeah we all live together in
this wonderful abode in Niceville which
I'm sure is now burned down as like a
meth house or something but uh and what
was the I'm just kidding nice house not
really but right outside a nice Ville
you would see houses that would I hadn't
exploded yeah outsider in badvel right
across the river we throw stones
Niceville there's a lot of pressure what
was a family dynamic like was this a
family that it's costly trying to crack
each other up yeah yeah we're all mess
around this one you're the youngest
it'll yeah yeah I'm the youngest and the
my niece is now the youngest you know
we're close but uh so yeah we would you
know I would freaking play video games
that was all the time we started out on
PC my brother got me into PC gaming is I
played a doom and doom Nukem 3d and
Ultima Online and Warcraft 1 and 2 and
they all all that in that period
Wolfenstein and I became good like so
actually it was kind of when when people
started playing with mice instead of
just using keyboards and there was
actually a lot of backlash against that
I think people playing like play Doom
use the keyboard look oh no dude it's
stupid to use the mouse like you know
and they would I would kill all of them
it was wonderful and I was the probably
you know I don't know how I was like
very young to be murdering everyone but
right about personality-wise
I mean how would you describe your your
parents and your siblings were they
where they like you I can't imagine
having a house full of people that had
as much like you good question here G at
comedic energy as you have I mean can I
just contain that I know he went outside
sometimes my they're all like they're
great they just had a really just nice
you know happy energy and I I didn't get
grounded a lot I think I got grounded
once Ford accidentally driving to my
neighbor's lawn when I was like 8 and
what you drove a car at 8 huh you know I
wanted to figure out why the car was
moving around so like my mom and dad
took her shoes to the house and I put it
in the reverse and we just kind of
rolled backwards I panicked and I just
hid under the seat until this car stuff
yes in their garden that's great
so you got punished for that but not
often yeah but my mom had to take care
also I wanted to take so they're always
kids around you know so it was kind of a
playful environment until I was like
maybe nine anyways so you were in the
daycare I was in carry on the teaching
the other kids about PC gaming use the
mouse kid yeah did you get in trouble a
lot
not until high school and I started all
the time because it was just joke - Joe
joke I was just you know trying to make
people laugh and I was getting in
trouble with like the the authorities at
high school there's the principal yes
some of the some of the teachers sir my
physics teacher he this is awesome he
okay don't do this but so I sat next to
my friend Ibrahim Mohamed his his name
and he's very very smart very smart guy
for a physics test and I you know I I
know I knew what I was doing I was doing
a good but I've made so many jokes in
the class I felt like he was lowering my
grade on purpose not you know just
because because it says my name on it
you know and whatever you always had
that kind of paranoia but so I said so I
copied his test exactly as it as a test
test which is exactly which it was very
dangerous but and then I got I got a 70
and he got a hundred and ten and some
why did I why did I get a 70 here's a
well he sound like Kermit the Frog well
uh obviously you didn't show you worker
this part nah look at this so I grabbed
his test I'm like I copied his test
office and that was so I mean did
anything change after that now I mean
still got the 70 turned into a zero
no I actually didn't I think he said he
left it which is weird but anyway but
you kind of proved the point that so the
principal wasn't on your side no I'm
like they're the same right but what's
it's difficult to read Ibrahim is
writing very difficult and I but I
learned how to do it I you know I took
my I had to do this so I had it like
show I'm like no this is Abby dude this
is a B squared and you know I walked him
through it and he's like you need to
work this out with your teacher your ear
they're making your case no I cheated
but I needed to do it so okay so you
made all these jokes you're the class
clown an SGA president hello guys what
president SGA president means that you
didn't government association so you
were I never actually did anything with
the student government but I ran for it
because we all got to make a video yeah
yes so he had to make speeches not
videos but that's the only reason that
you ran yeah that's gonna have the
audience you get the beauty for a small
school so you wanted to make a video so
we made a video for the morning news and
I did this thing and I was like if I get
elected I'm gonna make there be no more
ketchup packets because as you know
there's not enough catch this will may
be enough for one french fry some times
it's there's none there's not in there
sometimes because there's some kind of
error in the thing so just give us a
pump ketchup okay and also a boys
bathroom we need dividers between the
urinals yes or else they're not usable
and so that was my um I hope I didn't do
either one of those things but all I
tried to do is get a parking spot and I
failed pump ketchup and yep okay you're
that's the dividers are important yeah
very Orden yeah I won't usually urinal
next to another urinal do you get stage
fright when using urinals at like an
airport a hatred node dividers well I
mean I I know I weigh Tigh don't want to
I don't want to feet make somebody feel
like I'm encroaching on their encroach
what about the trough have you been to
school like gymnasium that's a trough I
mean that yeah it's got a little fun
that's that's fun it's like hey horses
do this with their mouths oh so you
don't write at that point because you're
excited about the force experienced a so
you went off to college I majored in
some sort of communications what it was
yeah I ended up on telecommunications I
started out microbiology and like this
sucks and where was that where with
school a University of Florida hmm you
started out microbiology how did you get
I was gonna be a dentist cuz my mom is
like you have really nice teeth
you should be a dentist I'm like I had
braces really yeah that was the
rationale I mean yeah I was like I'll go
with this for a while I had a you know
scholarship and I was like I'll learn
some stuff so you and me really good
grades in high school I guess yeah a
scholarship yeah and then I buddy
figured out you know I liked joking
around and then you know started
majoring Mike microbiology and that's
not a major I'd love to take you to
figure out that that wasn't I
I mean all your dear long and then I
switched to psychology and then for not
long at all and then telecom because I
mean it's the easiest one and there's a
class where you make a video one at the
end of the entire thing
okay so you say you're a guy who was
doing all these things to be the center
of attention of course and we can
totally relate to that interestingly I
think there's some interesting parallels
here because you know we were we ran for
student body president and vice
president whatever tried to be able to
speak to the whole school and we wanted
to be entertainers but then we went and
majored in engineering yeah so and I
think for us it was weird North Carolina
before it wasn't an option like we don't
know anything about Hollywood we don't
know him at California you can't be an
entertainer full-time I could not name
one person that I knew so you went and
did you get a degree yeah and did
engineering for a while geez that's
horror I mean in dearest what I mean we
wanted to go to film school but
dad said I'm not paying for that that's
that's not responsible writes that paper
both of your guys's degrees he didn't
pay for mine but I was gonna kind of go
wherever Rhett went cuz we were friends
and hey we both want to be filmmakers
guys go to it then I'll just do whatever
you do I guys you you guys are both good
at math and science you should be
engineers okay yeah your parents tell
you to be successful
yeah and the counselor the counselor
says that the parents they do something
responsible then kind of connects the
dots it's not really about tapping into
your passion it's just okay yeah this is
what you should do okay that's what
everybody's saying we'll be going
engineering right so when you change the
communications was it because you had
something in mind that you wanted to do
or that you knew you did not want to do
it's that I wanted more free time while
I was getting a degree in whatever right
because you know I figured out if it's
and I'm not gonna specialize in
something right now let me just use up
this scholarship money there as long as
I possibly can and figure something out
so bad like I basically was just being
lazy as long as I could until something
just fell on me and that's kinda what
happen and now in retrospect you can see
okay I ran for SGA as because of the I
got to make a video mm-hmm I started
taking these courses in college because
it's not got to make a video and were
you making lots of videos like in your
spare time in high school in college I
mean I would make some but I'm really
good when I have a deadline or when it's
a prize you know it's project mm-hmm and
I mean I made this video called tag for
one of my classes which is I I love it
it's one my favorite videos is this guy
he has a rainbow fanny pack and he just
like runs around and and has magic
powers in it as they all do of course I
love that and I made something called
candy planet that I animated in After
Effects which took forever but it was
sandy planet yeah candy plant this isn't
College Planet yeah in college I was
like my last me my last semester what
happens on candy planet what's just
about a world we're in a world where
carbon is sugar carbon-based life is
candy welcome to candy planet and so
like there would be these gummy bear
people and they adopted a golden gram
and little little races man well no
moves just a little Angelina Jolie or
something okay I'm well you know but it
was it was to call it you know whatever
my first girlfriend was black I dated
for three years I can do everyone well
let's talk about her instead a black
girlfriend one time oh yeah late never
did where the yeah we high-five just now
they just is that more a system what was
her name
yes
[Laughter]
Andrea Sandra and when was this in
college was high school well yeah early
no in Niceville Florida if you date a
black girl in high school what happens
to you uh I mean I was you know I we
okay here's how I actually met her so uh
I was invited to go shoot a video with
some people and we haunt me I'd love to
freaking see it now there's a long time
ago this girl Vicki invited me to like
shoot a video I was like oh that sounds
awesome I'll have a camera I'll do
anything it's great so we go over and it
was this it was a class project and she
wrote it out I'm like this isn't funny
she's like you're not in the class I'm
like you know I took my part and changed
it and made stretched it out and you
made yourself the star of course and it
was it was awesome and then I met her
and I made her laugh a lot she had a
great laugh and then we just started
dating what did you write in a kiss at
the end of the thing you know I did not
I don't know when I what did I kiss a
girl first it was like 10th grade or
eleventh grade well that would have been
around the same time yeah yeah well we
do yeah yeah sure so this a 10th grade
three years huh that your longest
relationship ever nope everyone they're
always things long they're Irish it's ok
her three years next one was like two
and a half next one was three next one
was three and they were else they're all
blocked off no controversy just I mean
in Florida I guess this is later than
when you know we're older than you so I
mean you got
parts of Florida or the South yeah the
South at a certain point you can you
know this is what you shouldn't date
some you know why people should date
white people what was the issue well I
mean uh for who I mean for you for well
not for you for the no I never
your parents nobody ever in the
community no I never got any like
weirdness about it I was just like I
don't care so like just take it and then
I was just always very adamant about how
much that sucks that you know people
would you know discriminate against each
other and so I was very but you know I'd
liked her and that's why it's pretty
simple for you yeah I didn't get it I
didn't get the whole like even though I
was you know because my family is pretty
awesome and they're very accepting so
yeah I never got any like weird flack
about it and you know I've never really
seen any like racism and my my high
school which is kind of cool
right well I weep being from Mississippi
and being so close to that area where
there is it is kind of weird
it's yeah right Mississippi would have
been a little bit different yeah so so
back to college I kind of derailed you
from the college experience you were
kind of discovering your creative DNA
that sounds like mm-hmm is that when it
happened
yeah I was trying to figure out what I
could do to make to get a bunch of views
and mmm because I wanted to think we're
making videos yeah well while studying
while skipping through different majors
yeah yeah pretty much they on the side I
was making videos and whenever it became
a class assignment it became like those
were the really good ones and I wanted
to always get class assignment and
that's kind of what the sponsored things
turned into direct oh you need this by
this point and it needs to be brand
friendly and all that Mike awesome let's
freaking make this great and I need more
of those I love
I need those deadlines but so what were
saying well this is transition from
being a guy at a in college she was kind
of discovering that he was creative and
he wanted to be creative you you
graduate and then and then what do you
do yeah when I graduate from college II
I I went back home lived my parents for
a little bit for like a couple months
and then my friend Adam who we actually
shot a movie
on my camera like so he knew I had this
camera de béxar on Herbie which my mom
took out a loan to buy it was awesome
because she just you know at some point
I was like I really really want to do
this and then so I you know I pulled her
away from the idea of like wanting me to
be what year was this
who knows I would say I got the camera I
mean it is in college so like dude I
have no idea I'm the worst but when was
it you - thousands I'm but this is pre
YouTube a little bit yeah so like oh boy
so I did a lot of okay mmm was pretty it
wasn't for YouTube videos no no I didn't
really make any edited videos pre
YouTube nope but you so you got I did I
got started on Medicare Medicare fee and
YouTube but like Metacafe cuz I saw that
they paid and I was like this is awesome
okay so when did you grow when did you
graduate from college what year was that
0:07 okay okay that adds up with the
2006 you kind of you joined YouTube and
your mom at some point you have this
conversation with your mom you're saying
I really want to do this and she takes
out a loan to buy you a camera Christmas
cuz like she you know just really wanted
to show that or everybody you know the
family which one of the really support
me what was this when he says to really
want to do this what would what did you
say that led to me acting I was like oh
I'm gonna do a thing and I'll become an
actor and be great and then she's like
oh you be such a great actor and then
she got me Cameron then my brother and
sister were probably like oh great so he
gets the freaking awesome camera but
they were always really nice and
supportive about it but I felt you know
it's gotta be a little weird but she
really did like she you know I went to
Cal I was you know I was a good kid I
think a lot of I mean certainly a lot of
people we've talked to on IRA's when we
kind of hear their story a lot of people
come from that oh I got the camera first
camera I got my hands on I was doing
this that and the other and I was
developing and it was almost like as a
director first I find it interesting
that you say well mom I want to do this
I want to be an actor hmm so I need a
camera
was that's not what you typically hear
and and you hear I want to be a I want
to be a director more because if you
want to be an actor well you could just
go to Hollywood or go to your local
theater or even in Florida and start
auditioning yeah something like that
like that was not gonna go up into
something else I'd rather just do it on
the Internet where anyone in the world
could see it so you wanted to be an
actor but you made it of an immediate
connection to this thing this YouTube
internet video thing that was happening
yeah yeah so it just kind of started and
then I at some point you know so my
friend showed me some Smosh videos and
and I'm like these guys are they're
freaking editing these comedy sketches
you do it one time and it's up forever
and it can get as many views as ever
gets and that was just a huge compelling
thing for me and so I wanted to figure
out how to make a video that they would
send to someone else basically yeah and
you know it's it's fun I love doing it
but your mom gives you this camera
you've graduated from college yeah and
what do you actually do you said you
only lived at home for and the camera
before I graduated okay so but so I had
the camera in college for a while and
then I started to make these edited
videos with my classmates and actually
one of them one of the videos was with
Andrew Meyer who's the don't taze me bro
guy and as framed him so he was in my
classes and I rewatched him getting
tased like the day of and I and also I
made a t-shirt on CafePress I think
mm-hmm that same day and put it in the
ending of the don't taze me bro remix so
like I like
in one day he's what'd you just do you
just made a shirt and you're selling
what I said on it he's really nice that
was all over the news yeah exactly
somebody I want to jump on this um news
clip went viral on YouTube yeah they
showed it on I think you know Colbert oh
poor and all that and you and say then
you remix it into a song but you had the
foresight I mean what because Smosh was
selling t-shirts you thought I don't
know I don't know I was trying to figure
out how to make the money back for the
camera that my mom bought you know and
also loans cuz I started taking out
loans I'm like yeah
I'm gonna hopefully I'll figure out a
job thing at some point but maybe I
could just get so many views that maybe
a company would want to pay me to do it
so it was like one of the first thoughts
I had on YouTube is that I could get a
commercial make a commercial if it's not
fused and someday a company would want
to like paid for so you never had to get
a real job well yeah I did actually
so when I moved to LA so my friend Adam
we you know he borrowed my camera and
shot this movie new low which i think is
on is on Netflix now and it's in a
couple places and then went to Sundance
which is awesome for the indie or low
budget so I got to get like free actor
swag it's amazing but you were the lead
in that he was the lead I was the second
but it was really fun just to do and
like see all the stuff and speed part
that process and actually all the people
that worked on the movie are now in LA
and like most of them work with me on my
stuff now hmm so like we have you know
it's fun like and we're still figuring
it out but it's coming together so much
better
well let let me ask you one thing just
take a quick step back you talked about
your mom
buying his camera for you obviously such
a pivotal moment that's the camera that
your friend shot the movie that made it
to Sundance yeah and you were you and
him where he was the lead you were in it
yeah he wrote it and edited it and
everything and he just brought my camera
like yeah you can borrow it if I can
behave I can act it so that don't tase
me bro thing was kind of a proof of
concept for you to I can I can sell
t-shirts I can this this can work mmm
how big did that get I mean I well I I
don't know what it's up to I think I got
a million music it maybe got like
800,000 views in the first week and it
took a while to get to a million it did
eventually and the shirts I think I sold
a thousand or two thousand of them and I
was getting $2 per shirt mm-hmm so that
was like four thousand bucks and this is
awesome but I'm like but I don't know
why don't I just printed myself and buy
in bulk if I you know if I know a phrase
gonna be a popular but there were no
like cabbie press was printing on the
man the only one and now there's more
competition and now they're really cool
I used Spreadshirt now no you guys you
guys do
dftba oh yeah oh yeah so take us through
the steps what happened after you
started to see that success and moved
out of the house did the Sundance thing
okay so I got a job when I my friend was
Adam Bowers was like you wanna move to
LA tomorrow and I'm like yes so
literally it was like tomorrow pretty
hilarious but I mean he'd been talking
about it for a while but he's like yeah
we're just gonna do tomorrow and then I
all right let's do it because my job
that I had just gotten off Craigslist
was a search engine optimization job
which has helped me a lot and so I you
know I never even met my boss from that
job but it was like you can move you can
move anywhere and do that yeah you kept
that job moved to LA yep
and I mean it's not like there were all
these youtubers in LA yeah where they're
starting to be just 20 Jen they were
just starting to be yeah yeah yeah and
but I wanted to go on auditions and
stuff like that so were you going did
you take the traditional actor route as
like plan a um I I don't know I mean a
little bit like I kind of thought if I
made the best video ever that actually
showed me acting I would possibly a cast
in something or get representation and
maybe do commercials or whatever but I
also you know hoped that I could get my
videos like popular enough to make that
be my job so I could get all the stuff I
have written since high school I still
have so many things that I still think
are funny that I can't haven't done yet
right well I think that's that that's
something I want to talk about is you
know you have gotten so prolific on
YouTube I think you're the only person
with two channels on the top 50 most
subscribed no that's awesome and
youtuber I believe so yeah yeah you you
are you know you just got so much
content coming out so much it's
successful it continues to grow
you're not like a lot of people who got
kind of started at the same time that we
did that saw a peak a few years ago and
it's they're struggling on their channel
know you've still got great ideas you're
still getting traction you're already
audience is still growing how do you
have a life ah it's hard I mean I
you know I definitely it's a thing that
I now actively pursue is like friendship
because it's important you know it's
important to be there for people and
it's important to like let them be for
you to be there for you sometimes and
you know it's also you know it's good to
know
good people and keep them in your life
and that is something that I definitely
like you know I would only spend time
with my girlfriend like you know that
was it because I'm working all the time
and we lived together - like I live
together was like pretty much yeah - did
two girlfriends in a row three years
each just let the other mm-hmm because I
shouldn't cheaper yeah basically don't
like to live together knows all the same
times great yeah so I don't know like
how that kind of fella play just cuz was
you know cheaper and like we got along
really really well and you know I just
making jokes and I just liked a people
with really good laugh well at some
point at some point or points in there
you also dated people who were youtubers
maybe and maybe that was their strategy
in that well okay we could work together
and be I'm not sure what I can is that
public knowledge
I know Olga is okay so you dated Olga
and and the other one but uh the other
high-profile maybe potentially so that's
not public knowledge I don't know I
don't know I mean we never talked about
it right it's weird it's a weird thing
because it's there's this can we make it
public knowledge now I mean I was over I
asked her right I don't know I don't
know really I know but I was I didn't
hide that we spent like all the time
together um yeah she was in your mean I
was looking for no logs and she's in the
vlogs so everybody already know don't
you know why he's together feeling like
I just wanted to be you know respectful
and like have her like say it you know
well how long were you dating I mean a
while you said you dated everyone for
three years I know it wasn't that I just
like six months so in the six month
period there wasn't this conversation of
okay we're gonna void together but we're
gonna we're never gonna say that we're
in a dating relationship
like you didn't have that conversation
no what we did we just I think I don't
really remember why it was like that but
it was it was a weird thing because it's
like do you feel more valuable if you're
single you know and and so that that was
well I'm not sure who who's had that one
through did you ask that question I you
just thought that question I maybe maybe
I just thought I don't know I mean I I I
didn't I didn't care but it is a thing
where it's like you are a person but
you're also a business and your business
what's gonna happen to that is it gonna
be good because here's my first thing is
if I someone knows so I have a
girlfriend who it is s weird sometimes
like cuz you know people can make them
uncomfortable and then it turns it into
your performance your relationship as a
performance and so you know and we blog
together all the time
but you know it was it was kind of we
just try to keep that thing private I
guess it's weird it's a weird thing to
even think about but with but with Olga
it was not you get she didn't care and
you didn't mind so it was more public I
mean yeah yeah it didn't matter how long
how long did you guys date I think like
eight months I'm so bad with hate moths
ish yeah more but time knowledge are you
still friends with yeah yeah why don't
both of them I talked to Olga more but
I'm equally you know I'm we're gone good
terms but it's just busy people are busy
where everybody we know you didn't
anybody now know I sort of was for a
while and it's just it's tough it's
tough to get that because you have to
I'm build I'm doing so many different
things at once that if all of a sudden I
miss so let's go to a movie or something
and I'm like 10 15 minutes late cuz I
was stuck at a charity event which is
done so horrible but I mean you know
it's not just that you know it's a it's
a buildup of that but I happened to be
like a moment this is very funny but uh
and then it turns into my stuff when
charities involved I know Michael are
you more important than chair
of course you are baby but chip it's
charity the word I know it's charity
like I I said that and didn't work
anyways yeah and that was it that's
wonderful I mean that's was maybe
sparked the I think that was the moment
of like she doesn't think I'm ever gonna
be there for her you know because I have
so much stuff I freaking do but uh the
video game that we've been working on
that you know has to be good takes a lot
of time and you know I I didn't realize
how much and it's fine cuz I love it but
like how much work it takes to make a
frickin video game I understand I mean
especially when you've raised six
hundred forty-four thousand dollars to
make it and everyone knows exactly how
much money that is a little strange but
it's also they don't know how much it
cost to ship it out I forget what the
game actually end up costing but we're
over budget but well that's what but
that's not the point because we're
talking about love life yes I think the
energy thing is your point is you're
very busy and you have a lot of demands
on yourself professionally because I
mean I we know the feeling you're at a
crucial point use more everybody in a
medium where you've got to continue to
can invent yourself really and make it
happen and I mean you just make this
statement support everybody yeah that's
on your team mmm you're talking I mean
you're talking you now have the ability
you have the pressure of being a
successful business so my question is
you I guess you're saying it's hard to
have time for a relationship but is
there also this aspect of it that's is
it difficult to turn off I guess I'm
curious for using it as a natural
entertainer like in all of us is what I
do you know all of our interactions I
mean we don't just hang out and sure
there's even microphones here right now
and there are always cameras around when
we're together so are there people in
your lives when you're just like with
your girlfriend with your friends that
you are able to turn off I mean well as
soon as they turn off its turn back on
you know I mean like as soon as I as
soon as I'm not recording something I
say something that's way funnier because
I don't have that oh I'm trying to get
the angle cuz I'd hold whatever and it's
and then I'm like no I got to record
this so you feel I mean so one of the
ditch
what are you to turn off turn off the
enter tuner
there there well there is I mean but I
like to hear you know I like to make my
friends laugh and as soon as I do I'm
like I think that was a funny joke I
don't put that in something so it's as
soon as as soon as I'm done with my work
I have to you know manage juggling like
you know what jokes that I just say just
hanging out like what do I write down
how can I put that into and then which
ones deserve the time that would take to
make it and do you think that's gonna be
the rest of your life I mean are do you
know I hopefully I'll have a team of a
billion lots of people that will just
help me put together every every single
project so you can so you can turn off
and be a real person I would think it it
impacted no that's a you're not a real
person but I mean I really get along you
know so I spend most have been times so
like I said I was trying to work on more
more of my friends that I really do get
along with and there are people that you
know I just love their doing but I don't
give them as much of me as I do to the
business because right now I'm trying to
grow a couple different things I'm
trying to do the video game and I'm
trying to you know like I got into a
bunch of projects at once we started a
podcast also last week because I need a
weekly thing onto buses that people can
look forward to because that's always
been my problem I had queue and fail for
a while and that was fun but I don't
want to always do a literal or whatever
you know I want to always be like hey
here we are let's hang out this is fun I
like that idea so let's see I even even
in the way that you answer questions
with us here on your biscuits is you're
so focused on ideas you have so many
ideas you are always thinking about
strategy you're always thinking about
how you can turn something that you can
have a natural disposition towards that
and that's why your that's one of the
many reasons you're so successful but if
I ask you a question about when are you
gonna find time for yourself mmm you
start to answer that and then you answer
a question about new content yeah yeah
so it's my natural drug I think about
like the two of us who have we think in
similar ways right so when I get there's
so much about the way that your ideas
come together that we can relate to but
we started all this while we already had
families so we have this natural
balancing mechanism that I can't you
know neglecting a girlfriend is one
thing neglecting a wife and children
it's you can't do that right so I
couldn't go home so we have this thing
where we okay we got to get home every
night except for like one night a week
we don't usually work on weekends and
that kind of thing we in school is okay
you don't have that balance in our life
well yeah that's true well I'm true but
I could to an extent so you know you
saying that you know you don't work on
weekends you don't work at certain times
that's great that's a healthy thing to
get into and like me like exactly what
I'm saying with the schedule if you know
you have to be done by 7:00 I do it but
if I don't have to and that there has to
be a real thing that I you know has to
fight like I try to get people to trick
me and do like you need this by 7:00
Toby and I'm like oh no and I gotta get
it done like you know then a minute
because it's simple like you do
voiceover sometimes but I buildup in my
head I go on so many freaking tangents
but if you have that then I think that's
good for you and then yeah you can have
free time but you know so I would go to
these fun things like we would go
horseback riding I mean my girlfriend
long time ago or wherever and as soon as
you know we'll be doing like this is
kind of cool like you know there's some
people that can't go horse riding they'd
be cool to show this you know you know
what I mean
so everything I wanted to share with
people and like it's kind of annoying
sometimes if you don't live in the
YouTube world
that's why dating YouTube people is fun
which when you have two people who have
that mentality they I think that things
can get crazy though right uh I mean
maybe but I you know there was a lot of
fun
I got cuz we like I have to do my vlog
she'd have to do her vlog you know we
would also come up we would think of
like a funny little sketch we could do
and we would individually be working on
something and that energy is in the air
and then you just live in it I love it
and so now you're in a place where
you've got all these ideas you got the
other projects longer-term things that
you want to see come to fruition and
you're you've got a team around you now
as opposed to just you make a couple
people work on everything right yeah
yeah so I mean the first the first thing
that I did you know like first reason I
had to figure out business was because I
had to basically move my mom out of
Florida I tell you this she had like she
has a lung condition and she got six
ones live or whatever and this was a
like
while is like your to ago I don't think
we knew that so a year ago your mom was
given six months to live it was like two
one two years ago but yeah by a doctor
that you know he said there was nothing
we could do they live in Florida suns of
humidity she's had this like lung thing
anyways and so I googled it and
apparently being in dry climate would
helps people sometimes right because
there's less you take places for bad
mold and whatnot to grow and so I had to
quickly move everyone out to the west
coast and so you know they live out in
west coast in the freaking desert now
because that ever only everyone your mom
who who did you move uh mom dad nice
sister yeah
and my brother lives in Texas so you
move them to LA mm-hmm yeah for a while
and then now Vegas cuz heli is just
stupid expensive I wanted to have her
close to me circus here all the time but
you know it's just it's it's cheaper in
Vegas right and so that was a huge
driving thing so that was kind of like a
sprint it's like that's why I'm like I
gotta do this now
mm and dude I always freaking cry when I
talk about that I didn't today maybe
it's happened enough times that's good
so rowing so you you did you move them
out to Vegas I mean how is she doing
she's good I mean she's she's good she's
what's the condition i COPD it's like a
lung feeling it's just hard for her to
breathe sometimes but I mean she's
awesome she's the best freaking person
like you freaking you watched any video
with her and you can't just not love her
she's fantastic and you know she's
working with it it's so much better in
like dry place so it makes me feel
really good but then there's also like
now that that's happened and you know
I'm like yay that's good I all my
friends that are extremely talented that
got into jobs that I was like woo you
don't like doing that do you and then
there they of course they don't and so
I'm like come on let's do some other
stuff and so like you know I'm trying to
get Mike help my friends out wherever I
can
because and that's dangerous working
with friends I don't everyone it's all
about to do so I have to hire someone
else to tell them what to do right and
then like you said then there's a sense
of responsibility that you have to
support
you have to keep you have to you have to
support these friends that are now your
employees and you've done your part to
bring your family out here you know to
Vegas so it seems like you got a lot of
pressure there to remain successful it
is absolutely yes so you have to just
you know learn how to put that aside and
not think about it a little bit and then
you know they're smart you know and
we're worried it's it's nice it's much
better than what it was because it used
to be I all the time only ever work and
now it's like I'm getting the points
where I'm like hey do this and then let
me see if you can do it and then I'll
you know look at it later I'll try this
tweak this you know it's a long process
I respect you hearing your story here in
the amount of responsibilities that you
have and what you've accomplished and
you know developing your voice and
everything you've done and you know
count you a friend and think you're an
awesome guy and we like glad to have
heard the story here so yeah and thanks
for taking the time out of your crazy
schedule dude to sit at the roundtable
of don't like problem and that is a near
biscuit with Toby Turner a lot of you
have been tweeting in us saying you
gotta get Tobuscus on ear biscuits and
it just happened we pinned him down for
a little bit we got him I mean the guy
is all over the place you know he's not
only all over the place literally always
doing something but his mind is all over
the place yeah I mean I I just think
that you guys got to experience the
unadulterated Toby Turner along with us
I mean you sure will ask a question and
you'll get he'll start on answer and
then he'll be flooded with other
thoughts and then you know a couple of
times it was like what was the question
because he's just his his creative
faucet is is full bore I mean for him to
say the turning point was when I just
said I'm going to go quantity over
quality this is no normal person saying
that I mean this is someone who's all
always at 11 so once that clicked in his
mind I mean it makes sense it is
turning point I mean there's certain
people who could do that and it would
just be a bunch of crap right but the
dude is he's so talented and I mean when
you turn the faucet all the way up it's
like people mean I want to listen this
whole thing but I can find the
highlights of it you know he's thinking
about all aspects of it but there's
there's gold in there well I think that
he created it all in front of his
audience on the Internet the thing that
I learned about Toby tonight tonight was
am I gonna cry about it I just
somethings my throat the thing that I
learned about Toby tonight was he is
that is who he is authentically you know
I think we would weep before he came in
here we talked about the fact that he's
a performer he's all he's always on and
we always see him in a performance
setting so we were interested to see
what it would be like to kind of sit
down and talk to him for an hour to ask
him some personal questions yeah and to
see if we could get I don't quote the
other side of Toby or the real Toby the
Toby that would turn off and I you know
I think his answer was you know there is
no off switch right there's no off
switch for him he said it himself there
is no off switch because he is even when
he's doing something horseback riding
for instance he's thinking about the
YouTube content that could come from
horseback riding right he's spending
time with his friends and you see on
horseback riding he writes down he
thinks right so I know you know I think
Toby horseback that's his next channel
probably that was very eye-opening to to
me personally because when I you know I
kind of pointed this out a number of
times during the your biscuit that we
have a similar approach to things you
know he started at a similar time he has
he's trying to do all these different
things he does a lot of music he does a
lot of branded projects there's a lot of
there's a lot of things in common now as
I stated on the podcast we haven't been
nearly as successful as him but me and
you really like we we only have so much
energy I think the thing about me and
you is that we kind of we got a run out
when we turn the faucet on when we turn
it up to 11 me and you kind of like
start getting headaches and get tired it
but it reduces to a trickle pretty quick
right you know and I hate to see
somebody there's the well dry yeah to
see somebody who
you can turn it on you can turn it up to
11 and it just keeps going I mean I
think eventually did he's gonna have to
slow down and I think that he's putting
some things in place with the team and
that kind of thing that he's not gonna
go insane I think that's the one thing
too that I noticed is I did not see
somebody on the verge of mental
breakdown by any means I saw a guy who
this is his life this is how he thinks
he's got more ideas than he has time to
do he gets off on it he loves being
creative and he's not about to implode
by any means he's just gonna keep being
a prolific creator and I mean on top of
that there's a sense of responsibility I
love the story of his mom took out a
loan to buy his first video camera so
that he could pursue his dream of being
an actor and an entertainer and then he
takes that camera and then builds a
career so that he can relocate his
family from Florida to Las Vegas for for
health reasons and basically rescue his
mom I mean that's a beautiful story and
there's there's that sense of
responsibility you know that is
admirable that it's not just he's this
creator who can't help himself but he's
also in his net and he's also a
businessman mm-hmm who thinks very
strategically about these things and
always has but he's also a family man
who's trying to figure out you know how
to help his mom and how to have a
girlfriend who may or may not be a
vlogger you know yeah right well you
know what I know I couldn't do it I'm
glad he's doing it and he's doing it
well and there's this sense that weaving
caps
we've encapsulated a moment the best ear
biscuits I feel like are the ones that
are like that like this time capsule
that okay this guy the capsule is not
being buried in this innocence this
capsule is kind of being launched into
another stratosphere and that's what I
feel like for this guy tech to carry the
cheesy capsule analogy you think we
should have called the the podcast time
capsules with rhett and Link being
launched into space that's what base
caps what toby is easiest
one somewhere so this is Astrid this
moment this is a space capsule version
of an air biscuit yeah I think it was
you put an ear biscuit in a space
capsule you know what that could be like
an experiment we could we could start a
Kickstarter we could raise money to put
a biscuit inside of a rocket that will
go into orbit see what kind of effects
happen on the biscuit bring it back down
and then sell it to the highest bidder
who then has to eat it that's the idea
that I just came up with Wow you can
understand what I said
I kind of phased out somewhere in the
middle and then when I tune back in you
were talking about somebody eating it I
was like well that's my plan my plan all
along is that there will be an actual
biscuit recipe that is like the official
biscuit recipe of ear biscuits and then
we'll shoot it in a space all right
thanks for listening tweet at Toby at
Toby Turner on Twitter and let him know
what you thought and remember to support
this show by leaving a review on iTunes
and checking out our sponsors
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes it fast and easy to create your
own professional website or online
portfolio for free trial and 10% off
your first purchase go to Squarespace
calm and use our offer code R and L
thanks for listening we'll be back with
another your biscuit next Friday
[Music]
[Music]